[Music]
once more into the breach dear friends
Brown bullet heading up the hill heading
the hike Runyan let's let me see there
she goes
swam minute minute minute minute minute
minute minute minute minute minute
minute minute minute minute minute
minute Shiki look at this look at how
much joy
show him the joy kid [ __ ] such
exuberance they're trying to run into
traffic she's so excited can you imagine
being that happy about anything in your
entire life it's crazy here we go man
heading up Runyon kids hiking once again
trying to stay healthy Battle of the
Bulge never ends I am a weight watchers
were rather strike that aaww they
changed names ww ambassador man tell
it's not enough to just not eat crap you
also gotta get some motility going they
tell me so me and the pup we're gonna
sail up Runyon Canyon once again went to
the once upon a time in Hollywood
premier last night with the kid and kids
in the movie my kid so she got us
tickets man finally this kids paying off
after 20 years she a little money pit
man but now I'm getting free tickets to
movies we got free popcorn I'm just
about even with this kid now
movies wonderful Quentin classic Quentin
wait till you see the last half-hour but
it was sweet man it was nice
you know Quentin's movies particularly
Reservoir Dogs made me write dialogue
where I write dialogue that's why
like in Reservoir Dogs
speaking of reservoir dogs the you get
those off there I don't need those yet
it's not that bright yet but it will be
I'm running in reservoir dogs they open
with the conversation about the like a
virgin
dissecting Madonna's song when I saw
that I said that counts that counts his
movie dialogue oh my god
I we dissect pop culture all the time we
talk about movies the way they talked
about like a virgin so Quentin was a
light showed me the way and then when
Pope friction went out he put the
clerk's trailer at the top of all the
prints he allowed that said yeah because
you like the movie which was awesome for
us because that movie went out of like a
thousand screens so to go to the sea of
those who's trying to start some [ __ ] to
go to a premiere of a quantum ooh V and
see my kid in the movie house nuts
real nuts hey Saturday if you're in the
LA area Hollywood babble-on with me and
Ralph Carmen we're gonna be talking
about everything that happened in San
Diego plus lots more tickets at sea smog
calm reboot Roadshow don't forget that
reboot Roadshow can't see the trailer
for Jay and Silent Bob reboot get
tickets come see is that the fathom
screenings October 15th and 17th all
right now that I've sold now I can die
properly on the hill I'm wearing this
non sweaty shirt it's caught Oh what's
she getting into let's check it out what
is it man
some other dog [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah good times
[ __ ] that's good
don't you go there
but this shirt
it's like called a brand called Tesla I
don't think it has anything to do with
the car but it has a Spanx like effect
to it ladies if you know what that means
it's very keeps everything together man
here's my shirt today
is this shirt I'm wearing Hot Topic
doing a bunch of Jane ssambap shirts
this is today's shirt hetero life mate
gross to wear myself and my chest I know
but how am I supposed to ask other
people who wear me on a t-shirt if I
won't even do it so I do it but this
thing is kind of Spanx he keeps
everything in tight you know I feel a
bit like a sausage but it's nice I get
why the ladies wear Spanx now just keeps
it all in a bunch of thin dudes and
girls out there going like keep what in
trust me just gives you lose weight tell
me and everything goes back to normal I
got a bunch of droopy hanging [ __ ]
skin but I guess one could get removed
surgically but I I never going under no
knife again unless I'm having a [ __ ]
another heart attack voluntary so I'll
just wear two skin a reminder of where I
was
hi good morning everyone's starting
their Runyon walks man maybe on the way
down thanks man okay alright so it
begins you can smell the scent of dogs
everywhere including mine who is just
ready to fight with everybody sorry man
dogs just ready to [ __ ] start [ __ ] um
and as you could tell about us and my
boys
oh she's shitty sorry umm fabs law
people come on we're on our way
no fighting dogs people will be like
they'll come up to shaggy with their
dogs and they'll be like like I'll pick
shakey up and they'll be like hold my
dogs friendly and I'm like my dogs not
she's a real [ __ ] temperamental yeah
man share me talking about hey let's
take a peek
what is it Schecter
weighing your options alright enough of
that you didn't tune in just to help me
show you my wiener here we go
journey of a million mile keep goin no
fightin I don't know there's a million
miles but guys shakey keep seeing dogs
stopping my crazy all right we're on our
way kids it's dirty it's early well it's
not that early it's like 9:30 or
something like that I got up at 7 and my
intention was to do this at like 7:30 so
I'll just smoke a joint and walk up the
hill give me some of that caviar Gold
welcome Dale
oh it's another wiener dog we love it
when was the other wiener dogs well I do
shucks he's indifferent um so then I
smoked that cavity gold and then I was
like wow maybe the walking weight plus
we had some maintenance to do a lot of
the rebou Roadshow sales the shows have
sold out so we're adding second shows
and bringing in new markets and stuff
figuring out where we're going in the
gaps so more dates gonna be announced
and if the day near you sold out don't
worry most likely we've added another
show
all right here it is the walk proper
they got two different ways to do this
nice water before we go good girl
all right here at Runyon they got a
thing called the stairs which er you
know it's more jagged and a little
tougher to get up I take what they call
the stroll it's paved see all the way up
but the stroll is more of an ironic name
than anything else I don't know about
strolling don't fight don't be fighting
with people keep going
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh futures up here face
front true believer today we got a fat
man beyond at the cantina dog breed but
I sold out I'm going on a meeting today
about pitching on this show which would
be very cool if I got long shot but good
go in and pitch anyway hope springs
eternal still here still above ground
got to fill the days might as well try
he's be more
afraid to go in other people's stuff
easy to be an independent artist because
that means you don't have to risk
rejection um but you know you'd grow to
change and he realized risk of rejection
ain't the worst thing in the world
especially when you're podcaster 17 look
at this dog everything's a story so even
when you fail you're getting content
just talk about I'm one of your show so
at that point you might as well try
things take the shot
the shots always worth taking someone
take the shot today
somebody needs a little break oh come on
kiddo miles go before we sleep uh let's
see what you guys want to know hey Kevin
when will the new Jay and Silent Bob
reboot be on theatres October 15th and
17th
there's sneak preview screenings with
fathom so probably at a theater near you
then
October 20th we start the Jay and Silent
Bob reboot Roadshow October 20th 1995
also the day that Mallrats opened so
October 20th 2019 we're gonna we're
gonna show him a little more ass cuz we
go back to the moment miss movie as well
so that tour begins we got City best
City Hall the dates for reboot roadshow
calm us going into that city means we do
a bunch of press so after our rebou
Roadshow event then the movie opens in
that city uh had theaters and stays for
as long as anyone gives a [ __ ] which I
sure you won't be long
so three ways to check it out one by
fathom October 1517 one on the Reaper
Rochelle and then once if you're new you
after the reboot Roadshow comes to your
town that's our plan it's a you know we
don't have the crazy marketing money
making a movie you know is expensive
enough marketing a movie sometimes way
worse
so we're marketing we're smart getting
we're combining all the things we know
about what we do in our day job touring
and whatnot with what we did in our
original job making movies so we did
this with red state we can't perfected
it with Jayne Samba super groovy cartoon
movie and now we worked to get it to a
place where reboot was possible
heading into it you know we knew we
would never be like an ultra world wide
release with commercials on TV so you
have to use your wit and so this is what
we came up with two years ago and then
waited to implement it and so the plan
was always like tickets go on sale the
day the trailer drops that happened
Thursday so far so good guys been so
supportive selling out cities for us so
much so that we're at another show so
yeah man you're gonna have three
different ways to see the movie I know
it's not as easy as like it opens Friday
everywhere like Marvel movie but in many
ways kids this is so not a Marvel movie
not nearly good enough to be a Marvel
movie but enjoyable nonetheless and we
got an audience so we made it for him
well I'll be honest I made it for me
there's my post heart-attack movie the
one that has to stand
as the testimony case the old heart
comes back at me there you go good drink
it look little dog water fans here okay
you gonna walk away from free water free
water water shaky um huh that's adorable
KY shoot that dog not like shootable
with the phone look at that pretty doc
see with the long hair this one's 14 but
she's so shitty
but look see look at her she's like all
I want to do is fight don't you
recognize one of your own
Doxey man no doc see on doc see violence
look at her she just wants to charge
that dog wants to be friendly yeah yeah
it's pretty horrible thank you yeah doc
see on doc see crying man and my dog is
always the perpetrator why can't you why
can't you enjoy seeing somebody looks
like you we're all we're all the same
man um all right it's getting tougher
now she's lock it up this is the worst
part of the walk sometimes shaggy locks
up all right now I'm in front of you
I'm in front of you she's like I don't
give a [ __ ] let's go down
can we go down stop looking at that doc
see come on Kim woohoo I'm a'ready
all right
up we go okay what else we got
that story from a podcast a while back
when you've stayed in Toronto with a
couple having sex I seriously seriously
have never laughed so hard I hope to go
to the roadshow in New York thank you
yeah the New York dates about to be
announced soon so you'll be able to get
at Jersey dates are coming next as well
that's what we were discussing yesterday
it just took us a little minute longer
all right I'm gonna jump off things are
getting hard and shaky apparently is in
caring mode right now so thanks for
hanging out don't forget them in Hot
Topic selling this sweet hetero life
mate shirt hot topic calm there's link
probably in my Twitter well that's it
trying to make it up that hill kids
insert metaphor here thanks for being
here
thanks for being encouraging it's always
nice to see the comments in the comments
all right like go [ __ ] yourself I'll be
die on that he'll appreciate that all
right
[Music]
you